[Musique]
voilà on peut encourager
vous voyez qu'il y a également des
supporters vous l'avez vu il y a
quelques instants des fidèles des laïc
qui sont intrigués par le fait que des
prêtres peuvent aussi jouer au football
et donc ça aussi c'est une joie une
réussite pour nous de découvrir les
prêtres autrement sous un autre angle
[Musique]
alors l'ambiance est super très
fraternelle ça nous permet de nous
rencontrer d'abord et après le niveau je
dirais hétérogène il y a même dans
chaque équipe il y en a qui savent bien
jouer au foot et d'autres un peu moins
mais c'est ça qui est sympa aussi
je vais sans plus tarder ici tous donc
et bonjour aussi ce petit mobiliser les
prêtres puisqu'ils vont jouer un rôle
vraiment important dans la mobilisation
de l'église mais notre objectif c'est de
mobiliser tous les fidèles
mobiliser les établissements scolaires
pour qu'ils soient ouverts pour
accueillir des volontaires mobiliser les
jeunes puisqu'on compte sur 2500 jeunes
à l'été de jeux olympiques pour pour
porter nos églises pour faire en sorte
qu'elles sont ouvertes et puis augmenter
nos projets de solidarité
[Musique]